I had written this one the part of Uncle
Pete actually I wrote it for Joe Pesci
right that's why I had in mind and I got
Joe Pesci's phone number my manager got
it and I called him he said where the
[ __ ] did you get my phone number first I
don't know you I don't know you and he
right he said I watched some of your
stuff after I got because I left him a
message right
I watched you stand up which I can tell
you just trying that and you're no good
at it he taught me you're no good
he said quit that now oh my god kidding
no use being serious you you stupid [ __ ]
he said you're as an actor you're okay
right
but the stand-up you get out now were
you looking for you you weren't looking
for an opinion no I wasn't and he said
but I'm calling Italian I don't want to
do your show but but I just want to give
you a little cheer and tell you as an
actor you got a future if you stick with
it that's what he said now what and I
said I'm Joe you have to let me pitch my
show to you and I actually went to his
house in Jersey New Jersey and we talked
about he liked the scripts yes and he
liked what I wrote for him and we I was
there for a whole day and night oh wow
great guy I had a great time with him
and and and the answer was still no he
said no but while I was there he
lectured me about don't ever eat a
woman's [ __ ] he gave me this whole
thing about never go down on a woman he
cause of that throat cancer right no why
not go down on it makes you beneath her
and you can never rise above a man he
said this whole thing to me got a poem
and I said to him you know I need to I
need to write that into this show and he
let me have it and and and it's in the
show yeah but in the end he declined to
do the show don't eat [ __ ] now get the
[ __ ] out of my house [ __ ] out of my
[ __ ] house you unfunny away upside
down you should hit you with bat